merci la parole est à monsieur michel
sordi
merci ma question s'adresse à madame
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé madame la
ministre
il y a deux jours vous déclariez sur
bfmtv je vous cite je crois beaucoup en
la nécessité de sauver des hôpitaux de
proximité
et pourtant hier vous avez accepté la
fermeture du service des urgences de
l'hôpital de thann situé dans ma
circonscription
ce sont 120 mille personnes qui sont
privées d'un service d'urgences de
proximité dont trente mille habitants
dans les fonds de vallée qui se trouve
désormais à plus d'une heure de route du
premier service d'urgence ce qui va bien
entendu à l'encontre de la promesse du
candidat hollande de fixer un délai
maximum d'une demi-heure pour accéder
aux soins d'urgence
hier vous avez laissé quatre des cinq
médecins urgentistes quitter leur poste
d'urgence de thann pour être muté dans
un autre établissement leur demande de
mutation a été acceptée par le centre
national de gestion du personnel
hospitalier sans que l'hôpital de thann
ait été informé et n'ait eu les moyens
de retarder leur départ le temps de
trouver une solution pour réorganiser le
service
c'est inadmissible madame la ministre
comment peut-on continuer comme vous
l'avez fait en 2015 à réduire le temps
de présence des médecins urgentistes
dans les établissements alors même qu'on
en manque déjà beaucoup madame la
ministre
le groupe hospitalier sud alsace était
précurseur dans la démarche de groupe
hospitalier territoriaux par son ampleur
nous avons bénéficié d'une aide d'un
million d'euros en 2015 pour la mise en
place d'un service de soins de suite et
d'oncologie mais d'aucune aide
supplémentaire pour le moment madame sur
l' enveloppe de 200 millions d'euros que
vous venez de développer pour rabbit et
des bâtiments qui sont vétustes
réhabiliter c'était une promesse qui
avait été fait
alors madame la ministre pouvez-vous
m'indiquer quelles sont les solutions
que vous pouvez apporter rapidement pour
maintenir des urgences du centre
hospitalier talent pouvez vous me
confirmer que le groupe hospitalier sud
alsace va bénéficier d'une aide
supplémentaire à l'état madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
michel sordi c'est vrai que l' agence
régionale de santé a été amené à
suspendre l'activité du service
d'urgence de l'hôpital de thann pour une
période que je souhaite la plus courte
possible
pourquoi cette décision at elle été
prise parce que il n'y a plus
suffisamment de médecins des médecins
ont quitté l'hôpital et c'est dans le
droit français la possibilité qui leur
est donnée dans la mesure où ils ont
considéré ne pas avoir tous les
instruments les personnels disons
permanent pour les postes existent il y
avait un recours à l'intérim médicale en
quantité excessive et les médecins ont
considéré que tant qu'il n'y aurait pas
la suppression de l'intérim médical et
ne pouvait pas exercer dans de bonnes
conditions je souhaite que nous
puissions attirer des professionnels qui
permettront de rouvrir ce service
hospitalier c'est ce à quoi nous
travaillons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle pas seulement pour l'hôpital de
thann malgré tout j'ai mis en place un
plan d'attractivité pour les praticiens
hospitaliers pour accélérer la carrière
de ceux qui vont dans des établissements
plus isolé ou moins spontanément
attractifs comme celui de thann je vous
indiquais monsieur le député que j'ai
mis fin à la tarification à l'activité
exclusive dans les hôpitaux de proximité
précisément pour permettre le maintien
de ces hôpitaux de proximité je
terminerais monsieur le député en vous
disant que lorsque j'entends les
programmes de certains de vos candidats
qui annonce la suppression des hôpitaux
de proximité pour faire des économies en
matière de santé je veux dit qu'il va
falloir choisir ou défendre votre
hôpital ou défendre vos candidats mêlés
2 à l'évidence ne sont pas compris